maybe this hundred year period is the
period that had the great capitalistic
outcome and from here on out particle
physics is not going to produce anything
that someone can monetize we should not
stop it
even if that's the case because we are
humans who want to know things and and
making sure that we give people the
capacity the time the resources the
space to actually pursue those questions
kind of on behalf of humanity that
sounds very grand
um no is that true giving people that
that capacity is such an important thing
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from Magic
welcome everybody to what promises to be
one of the nerdiest episodes of the year
and that's when two experimental
physicists get to just seriously nerd
out over our favorite subject which is
building coolest stuff in the universe
and using it to learn hitherto unknown
things and that's Professor Susie Sheehy
of the University of Melbourne I think
is correct pronunciation and Oxford on
occasion as I understand it uh you're
the 10th axonian to be on uh I think
you're the first melbournian to be on
but I don't know
the second a second Australian to be
honest we had Luke Barnes on uh recently
uh this this year already in 2023 but
today it is because of a phenomenal book
that I've been waiting and asking you to
come to the podcast for over a year
because I mistakenly thought it was
already out in America but it actually
came out in the UK first and that's
called the matter of everything and that
will be the subject of today's
conversation and Susie as you know
because I just told you on this podcast
we love to do the thing you're never
supposed to do which is to judge a book
by its cover but I always say what else
do you have to go on you know you don't
every book doesn't come with a with a
crystal ball that you can look into
um so tell us a particularly pretty
cover this one yeah it is beautiful
evocative and so we love to understand
the title and the cover art but
especially the subtitles because usually
the author sometimes the author doesn't
have control over almost anything but
the subtitle so tell me Professor how
did you come up with the name the title
of the graphics what what did you uh use
as inspiration for this wonderful new
book
[Music]
this is actually the second release so
it's already out in the UK and
Commonwealth which actually had a
different cover and a different subtitle
so that's an interesting change so the
the contribution of the main title the
matter of everything was mine and
actually my literary agents we we came
up with that together
um and I I just as soon as we hit on it
it was like oh yeah it has to be that
because it's sort of a double meaning
right
um so it's literally a book about meta
and meta literally makes up everything
um and uh at the same time it's sort of
talking about uh the matter of
everything which implies sort of all of
the stuff in our world including
Technologies and modern society which
the book also hits on so that kind of
worked well
um the original subtitle for the UK
version is called 12 experiments that
changed our world
um and actually I a lot of of people
prefer the the new US Canada subtitle
which is how curiosity physics and
improbable experiments change the world
I think it's just a little bit more
descriptive of what's actually in the
book and the fact it's a it is a story
about experiments and particle physics
very good so this book covers these 12
phenomenal you know kind of world and
universe changing experiments but the um
the picture on the cover at least the
one you're holding now it's not of a
modern experiment right unless I'm like
I miss some serious symbolism there
no it's just I I think it's beautiful
there's this um pattern of just the the
electric fields around two parts there's
a positive charge a negative charge it's
just the electric field lines sort of
displaying the invisible forces of
nature and I think that's
um that was a lovely way I actually
didn't that was the first cover art they
proposed to move the US version and
everyone loved it
um people have pointed out some other
slightly controversial things about the
cover which I also love and I wonder if
that's something that you have picked up
on
um hello Susie please so you notice the
colorway is really beautiful I love it
and there's a pink so a couple of people
have pointed out
um and you can cut this from the podcast
if it's too much a couple of people have
pointed out a Georgia o'keefe-esque
element
of the pattern those dirty-minded
physicists come on
and you know what as soon as someone
pointed that out to me I was like oh
this is definitely the cover for me then
as a female physicist working a male
dominated field and also declared
feminist right exactly and all
throughout the book I've tried to
reintegrate the stories of women whose
stories are normally left out of the
history of physics and so the fact that
there is like a subtle feminist angle to
the cover just yeah nailed it yeah
that's great that's right although we
have to be careful with our metaphors
and so forth here I thought it had
something to do as a feminist I thought
it had to do with you creating you know
what could be called I believe there's
third wave feminism if I've if I've if
I've gotten that right but you are the
unique person on Earth perhaps to coin
you know particle wave feminism I I
think you could make that Duality better
than anybody particle wave Duality
feminism for sure for sure let's do it
let's do it in there with me that's
right you talk about that in this very
book you talk about the Mysterious World
of quantum and how it was revolutionized
and how we made the transition and just
you know people think all these
discoveries are hundreds of years old no
the experiments you talk about are some
of which occurred in the last 10 years
and obviously cover the Higgs we've
covered that a lot and you do sing the
Praises rightfully so of many of the uh
great heroines of modern science not
just physics I was just listening to an
interview I did with Ashley Yeager a
year ago about Vera Rubin who was a
Titanic scientist worked here at UC San
Diego with the Jeffrey and Margaret
Burbidge and Margaret was one of the
Titanic physicists of the 20th century
astronomers of all time perhaps and I I
wonder if we could start with the first
dichotomy that is sometimes lost on the
general public when I go on podcasts or
sometimes I'm sure you've been on
podcasts people think of physicist is
all the same you know first of all we're
all you know Brian green or gen 11 or or
what have you but um what is the primary
distinction in your mind of an
experimental physicist what can he or
she most uniquely Tribute to The
public's understanding of science
yeah so I thought I thought that
was out of talking to people about
physics
when they knew I was a physicist
and that you know we can sort of blame a
little bit the fact that in popular
culture a lot of physics is presented
that way a lot of books are written by
theoretical visitors maybe because
they're the ones who have the time to
sit and sit down and write while the
rest of us are in the lab but in my view
yeah they're sort of I mean if we're to
create that dichotomy between theorists
and experimentalists some people do both
but an experimental physicist rather
than just looking at the mathematics and
the mathematical Concepts and trying to
create a theory from which something can
be predicted their job I sort of say is
much more nuanced so they have to keep
in mind and understand the mathematics
and the theory and work with it but they
also have to be able to look Beyond it
and to look for things that maybe nobody
has ever thought about before and nobody
has predicted and they also have a very
unique skill set so as well as having
the mathematical and theoretical
background and training as you know we
also have to have all these other skills
which you often only learn on the job
things like Electronics superconductive
and you know working with like
cryogenics things like back in the day
we've been glassblowing budgets oh my
goodness
bane of my existence
um you know being being able to just
design you know sort of almost verging
on engineering and being able to
understand how to get something uh
Precision engineered understanding
grounding Loops in the lab understanding
radiation shielding that's been my one
lately building my new lab
um so there's all these different skills
that we actually have to have as well as
signal processing Etc
um just to get to the point of doing
something which can create new knowledge
and yet when you combine all those
skills together we're able to do
something that I in my view a theorist
can't which is we can find something
which we never thought was out there and
that's a really powerful skill
and it kind of dovetails into my next
question which is you know do we need
more Drax or do we need more rutherfords
I mean they're both big figures in this
book
but you know kind of are We over
invested uh we have a lot of uh
contrarians on this podcast ranging from
Sabina hasenfelder to Neil Turok uh
decrying the the stagnation in
theoretical physics essentially for
those that may not have heard those many
many interviews uh there's a sense that
string theory has kind of sucked all the
oxygen out of the theoretical particle
physics world and therefore uh there's
not uh really room or oxygen molecules
left for alternative theories a but B
we're kind of beholden to this
unification dream that last bore fruit
perhaps in the in the late 1970s what's
your take do you think of like we're
under invested in theory over invested
regardless of the sub branch of of
theory you know whether it's particle
physics or whatever do you think if you
were you know Queen of the earth and you
had control over the purse strings not
just over Australian purse strings but
what would you invest in what would be
obviously you'd want some about both but
what do you think is is the most
fruitful Avenue for us to pick the high
hanging fruit that remains
yeah I think um obviously we have we
need both right and I think uh you know
I'd have to go through the numbers for
each individual country for like how
well we're investing in each of those
different areas although I I do agree
with the idea that we often you know
sort of jump on a bandwagon
um to the expense of other sort of
lesser researched areas and even the way
that our funding systems sometimes work
is that unless you're working in that
hot area you basically won't get any
money
um and money as gosh as it is to mention
it alongside curiosity driven research
money is what gets things done
um so that that that is an important
perspective
um I think in my view and one of the
things I've tried to really champion in
this book is is just the power of
experiments full stop now you can think
on many different scales with this
particle physics is at a point where our
future experiments on the large scale
are absolutely freaking enormous right
and are going to consume vast amounts of
budget to build any sort of future
collide a large experiment there you
know tens of billions of of dollars
thousands of people Etc so that is a
huge investment and I I do think we need
to be careful about how we make that
investment and not commit to something
too soon that turns out to be not the
thing we really wanted and that is
exactly the process that's happening at
the moment and we have international
processes to decide that among the
community and of course there's always
going to be people who are like oh no
this is completely wrong you're barking
up the wrong tree
um but I think as much as we are as
physical susceptible to things like
group think and ego and bias I think
when you've got that many smart people
who manage to actually collaborate and
agree on what they do want to build
together I I think in a way you should
go with that but not at the expense of
everything else so if you're not you
know if you're not involved in that like
hot big experiment and actually I My
Confession is in my career I've never
chosen to be on that big experiment so I
I only worked on the Large Hadron
Collider experiments as an undergraduate
and after that I've worked on other
projects and nowadays I design particle
accelerators for medicine so I sort of
stepped away from those big big projects
because I I just decided that wasn't
personally how I wanted to work so I
have a massive respect for people who do
the same and who go actually you know
what I can do this clever little
experiment in my lab or in my country I
can build this dark matter detector for
example is one that is being built near
me in Melbourne in Australia to do a
southern hemisphere version of the the
Dharma measurement that was made in the
northern hemisphere to try and confirm a
seasonal variation of dark matter which
will be important if we can do that in
the southern hemisphere so I respect
people doing small scale experiments as
well I think in a way my view is where
people appear to have gone wrong and I
am slightly an outsider here because I
work on accelerator it's not directly on
particle physics
my view of where some people go wrong is
they they really get into their own sort
of group thinking bias and we are you
know I like to say that even though
science is objective scientists are not
right so we do fall into the problem
science is done by scientists yeah yeah
if only we could do it with robots no
you're enjoying this video to leave a
thumbs up my thumb's a little bit
preoccupied with all Carl Sagan over
here but I hope yours is free enough to
leave a like it really helps me with the
algorithm and for extra credit homework
assignment leave a comment down below
what you're enjoying about this video
so so I think um I do really appreciate
the the dissenters the dissenting voices
and I think they have something valuable
to offer uh even if those dissenting
voices are often like no everyone else
in the world is wrong and I'm right
but it's worth listening to their
arguments you know right I'm sure you
get those emails I I get them all the
time you know Professor Keating uh I
have this great idea but everyone says
I'm crazy but you know they said this
guy Albert was crazy too and uh yeah I
just need the help with the math and and
then if you help me I'll split the Nobel
Prize I'll keep the money you know you
could uh but but the point I guess in in
right now we're in Winter you're in the
middle of summer uh we're in graduate
student recruiting uh okay so we've got
graduate students I was just on the
phone with a brilliant person no I won't
tell you his name because you might
poach him and he you might want to move
down there and then I'm trying
Australia's right come on over
give me the elevator pitch for why a
student should one to do experimental
physics generally but in particular to
work with Professor Sheehy on particle
adjacent but but certainly any I have to
imagine anyone who's working with you is
going to learn a lot about the the
history the background the experimental
methods what's so cool about that why is
that such a fun thing to do in this age
of you know kind of reverence for you
know just content creation on the
internet and YouTube Tick Tock videos
what is the uh kind of uh cinequanon
that would attract a brilliant young
graduate student to join your lab as
opposed to become a theorist or go into
work for Google
yeah really great questions so I think
um what attracts people and I'm going
off the experience of of people who've
come and joined joined my group here
right and I asked them usually like yeah
what what
um What attracted you to come and work
in this area and it was kind of exactly
the same that attracted me to the area
of particle accelerators themselves and
their instrumentation and the
experimental uh side which is that you
know all of these big ideas are amazing
all of these big ideas of how our
universe works and that theoretical and
conceptual understanding but at the end
of the day you know unless you're in the
arena unless you're in there and
actually building something and trying
to do it in a Hands-On way
um you're sort of missing in a way that
the fun of it and we live in this age
where so much of our technology is like
black box invisible to us
um you know if you can even code you're
like one step ahead but to be able to
actually build something with your own
hands that lets you experience the world
in a way that you otherwise can't see
and experience and then the added bonus
in my group is to then do something with
that knowledge go back to the drawing
board and design instruments and
experiments which can actually make a
difference to people's lives in the real
world as well as make a difference
potentially to the next generation of
hadron colliders or particle physics
experiments that potentiality of you
know you come work in my lab you're
going to learn the skills that can do so
many things in the world whether you're
interested in that practical everyday
application of you know extending Cancer
Care access to low and middle income
countries which is one of the projects I
work on or whether you want to work
toward the future circular collateral
CERN that's one of the things that I
find amazing in my field about
accelerator physics is that we mix
together all these different areas of
like plasma physics non-linear Dynamics
and electromagnetism and out of that
just comes this amazing growth of
opportunity of what we can do in the
world using the fundamental nature of
matter I think that's my yeah open my
elevator picture that's what people are
expected and then you can just hit them
with the book and say you know you're
yeah and here's a signed copy join the
group yeah
I make them pay I make all prospective
graduates in the paper no I'm just
kidding um so when I first heard about
your book I thought um you know it might
be kind of a Counterpoint to Hope yaren
has this book called lab girl which is a
lovely book she's a biologist a tree
biologist ecologist I think I think she
was at Hawaii but now she's in North
anyway I can't keep track of all these
people uh yeah I've read my book yeah
yeah it was it was interesting because I
think the issue of you know uh her
personal struggles are interesting and
certainly almost everything is Memoir
but what I love so much about your book
is that it's personal and you talk about
but you're again you're talking about it
from the perspective of professional and
what the Hallmark is of the book is that
you're you're kind of entreating the
reader to approach these incredibly
mysterious phenomena as a professional
not just like an interested account and
I wonder you know was that a conscious
Choice did you want to you know take
people more less on a memoir kind of
Journey as hope did which is a wonderful
book and I love it I've given it to as
people as gifts but was it less meant
intended to be a memoir so that you
could focus on that which Drew you to
become an experimental physicist
yeah I think
um at first when I first started writing
it it's my first book right it's my
debut so
um at first you don't know how to write
a book right and working through that
exact question was part of the process
of writing the book is how much of me
how much of my stories do I want in the
book versus how much of this is about
the the ideas that excite me and trying
to portray those ideas and
um eventually there was a sort of
compromise made of where sort of my
story leads us in and my story sort of
takes us out again at the end
and brings us back to today but then
within the book I chose to sort of lead
with the science and lead with that
Curiosity and lead with those outcomes
but I mentioned before that I rewrote in
these stories of women and I think one
of the wonderful things about doing that
I realized when we sort of Step Back
From the process
um and read the finished thing is that
their stories kind of tell my story in a
way without me having to to spell out
all the ins and outs in in a memoir and
what's interesting is that my us editor
it was actually the same editor who did
hope jaron's lab girl
um yeah so uh so we we've talked a lot
about that and about how much to include
it was also a you know I had a UK editor
in a US editor so there's always that
play in the publishing world of well
it's my decision at the end of the day
and they had they actually had different
differing opinions on how much should be
Memoir and how much uh should be really
science-led and I'm I'm really pleased
with with how it balanced out in the end
but because that because I I don't have
to sit through every interview with
people asking me about every incidence
of say harassment that I've experienced
because it's not in there
um
but at the same time I get to highlight
the women who really did the work and
that just feels so much more positive
and empowering to me to be able to bring
that story instead of like a negative
story about their experience or my
experience yeah I mean one of the most
towering figures and you know I've done
a video on my Channel about it I called
the most important experiment of all
time was Madame muscles
in the book about I wonder if you could
if you could pick a favorite you know
all of us who have children always say
you know we can't can't choose our
favorite child it's my mom used to say
it's like asking her to choose between
her left arm and her right arm which I'd
say Mom you're left-handed come on you
know you're obviously going to choose
your left hand uh but is there a person
male or female it doesn't matter but is
there a character is there is there a
figure that really stands out I mean the
one keeps coming back so often is
Rutherford you know and he just seemed
to have this brought to life by your
wonderful writing this outsized
personality which I never knew about I I
mean I remember seeing him on the way to
Antarctica we go through there's a
museum uh and there's there's a lot of
information about him and then I know he
was in Canada and so forth but and he
initiated so much of what we do as
modern prodigal physics he was kind of
my favorite you know if I have to
confess character in the book but do you
have a favorite is there is there an uh
you know a figure who really brought the
drama the passion the love that you and
I share for doing experiments to life
most for you I I feel like I feel like
that description is really describing
Ernest Rutherford and his approach and
um it may it becomes more difficult in
the second half of the book when we go
past World War II and then we get these
large collaborations and international
experiments because then it becomes less
about the individual and more about the
collaboration so it becomes difficult
then to just sort of say oh yeah this
amazing person from this era
um if if I if I had to choose someone
other than Rutherford it would be Bob
Wilson
um who uh who was actually uh the
founding director of what became
fermilab because he was this beautiful
combination of experimental physicist
kind of cowboy
um and and poet and sculptor so he had
this wonderful combination of skills in
the creative uh the Practical and the
theoretical which he sort of brought to
bear in his leadership of that project
and he his quote which I read in the
book
um justifying the sort of fermilab
project to Congress is one that I use so
much in so many of my talks because it's
so epitomizes why we do particle physics
do you want a job to read out just the
end of it if I can find yeah yeah I I
would love that yeah yeah let's let's
see if I can find it it is so poetic and
it actually I heard it spoken by Leon
Letterman at my college graduation with
Leon was of course a towering figure in
particle physics Nobel Laureate and he
quoted from this at the commencement
speech at Case Western where I went 30
years ago so yeah I would love it if you
uh if you have it handy otherwise we'll
make sure to put it on screen
um sorry yeah so Wilson was before
before the Senator John pistor
um he was asking him about this proposed
machine and it was 1969 and you know
obviously it's costly and it's risky
because they don't know what's going to
come of it because it's doing research
obviously
um and so and so at first uh Wilson
actually justifies it based on well
we're doing extremely difficult
technical things and and the outcome of
that always sort of pays for itself in
the long-running new technological
innovations which became true with the
teletron because they uh basically
industrialize superconducting wire so
that's why we now have MRI scanners
available but then
um but then Wilson really delves down on
the cultural aspect so the senator asks
him does uh does this project have
anything to do with the security of the
country and Wilson just says no so he
was involved in the Manhattan Project
he's a pacifist very strong pacifist at
this point
um and he will have nothing to do with
like defense and ever again so the
senator pushes him on it it's like
nothing at all he's trying to help him
justify it and then Wilson just knocks
it out the park he says it has only to
do with the respect with which we regard
one another the Dignity of man our love
of culture it has to do with are we good
painters good sculptors great poets I
mean all the things we really venerate
in this country and are patriotic about
it has nothing to do directly with
defending our country except to make it
worth defending
yeah and every time I get Shivers
everything
it's so evocative and so true as my late
great colleague particle physicist Hans
Parr who passed away sadly a few years
ago uh work he was Letterman's graduate
student actually and he used to say
things you know in his German accent you
know the relativity is is the highest
culmination of Western Civilization
Western Civilization what about the Mona
Lisa but if you think about it really
um I would only add experimental
verification of relativity because
relativity required mathematics advanced
communication
um uh and and then finally verification
and scientific hypothesis testing by
experiments uh and and we take it for
granted every day anytime we use you
know GPS device to get anywhere
um but I wonder you know when we're
teaching these things because the the
Einstein you know I have all these I
have all these thumb you know I've got
Carl Sagan around here somewhere I've
got uh Isaac Newton I've got Einstein
but I don't have any experimentalists
you know maybe a finger puppet of Susie
Sheehy uh but I I don't know if you'd
license your your likeness but the the
the you know the feeling I have is I
want my students to know as much about
Theory as any of the theoretical
graduate students studying theoretical
physics I just don't expect them to do
theoretical physics like come up with
some new Theory although some have you
know come up with contribution to
phenomenology or or you know perhaps
some analysis technology but what do you
think is this you know we've heard from
Lenny suskin another famous Ultra famous
uh theoretical physicist you know the
theoretical minimum what's the
experimental minimum is it this book
because I mean the book is is certainly
would be a component of it if I had a
you know come up with a curriculum for
for bright undergraduates to kind of
what's the next you know how do we
become experimental physicist but what
about before this book takes place I
mean every author has to start the
narrative somewhere why did you draw the
line at the 20th century and beyond
oh goodness so that the choice of the
choice of the time scale to explain ex
is not the whole story of experimental
physics in fact it arguably ignores
thousands of experiments that um that
could have been beautiful right there's
there's many versions of this book that
could have been written
um so you know like Choose Your Own
Adventure but I chose the particle
physics route uh partly because that's
my background
um but also because particle physics
just has this reputation of being like
such an esoteric subject right such a
such a theoretical subject even like
yeah quantum mechanics yeah the
development of that happens somewhat
within the book
um nuclear physics uh you say the word
nuclear everyone just has this very
negative connotation radiation has a
similar connotation and then by the time
you get to choir because everyone's like
who cares uh it's not real you know like
so there's this there's this view that
um
the different things that I talk about
in particle physics people have a very
disjointed view of them
um and they also have this view that
they're very separate from our lives and
I just had this very strong feeling from
working in the field for so long that
like wait no this stuff underpins our
technology and we don't even know you
know most people don't even know that
it's there uh because they think that
physics is just a theoretical subject
and that it doesn't have ramifications
in the real world when you think about
things like how fundamental particles
work and so that was my like
key thing that I wanted to get across
was that this stuff really affects your
lives it may affect it on a long time
scale because of the innovations that
come from it it may affect it on the
short term because oh suddenly you
understand there's radiation raining
down on you from space and that affects
things
um so so I wanted I wanted people to put
those things together and I found that
the way to put those things together was
really through the experiments through
the that development and the discoveries
that were made not through the
theoretical angle in in my opinion
um but you mentioned something early in
in the formation of that question about
teaching and that's like a whole other
can of worms because yeah we teach
theoretical physics basically any course
you take in physics is almost entirely
theoretical physics and I agree with you
that I want my students coming into the
lab being able to solve hamiltonians and
being able to you know like do do
theoretical physics they actually need
it to do their experimental work as well
but then where are they going to get
these experimental skills from
and like some students are lucky enough
that they went to a high school or you
know that they have great Laboratory
um undergraduate Laboratories available
to them in their universities and some
don't uh and I was someone who really
didn't do that much in a Hands-On sense
when I was in school in science class
but I did do quite a lot sort of out of
school and like side projects
um and then in University I was quite
lucky that we have like this amazing
Suite of live demonstrations for
lecturers to use which I now get to get
to demonstrate which is awesome and they
also have like really good undergraduate
laboratory projects here but even then
even then there's this point at which
you have to learn to go beyond what's
written on the like lab script and
actually learn to Tinker and learn to
find your way through a problem building
a thing yourself and that um
that just at the moment comes from
experience and I do wonder if there's a
better way
in constructing the way that we teach
and talk about physics that would help
people
you know get get into that a little bit
more because it's it's such an important
skill uh and as we get more and more of
our technology as I said earlier you
know starts to look like it's a black
box and we don't understand what's
inside it
we've become so divorced from that
that's like well how many people
actually have those skills like are we
just going to machine learn everything
because we've forgotten how to actually
do anything
that's right when I have a list of uh
you know possible skills wanted and you
know to join my group I I always include
like you know did your mother own a
welding company you know like because
they they won't put those if oh I don't
know python or if I don't know yeah
machine learning uh tensorflow it's I'm
not I can't be a physicist but it's like
nothing could really be further from the
truth even Einstein had some patents and
and actually the things that he was most
kind of driven by his gdonkan
experiments were things like that
involved the observation of physical
phenomena in an experimental context uh
a magnet uh a compass and the
interaction between them that he called
something deeply hidden titled by past
guest John Carroll uh and uh or or his
famous you know thoughts on the
equivalence principle and the uh General
principle of general relativity that an
observer in free fall would experience
no gravitational force and that he
obtained and by thinking about it and he
called that his happiest thought and I
always say like to what extent could a
computer a know what it's like to free
fall and then B like what would it mean
that it has a happy thought so I don't
think we're going to be replaced anytime
soon by uh by by any sort of uh a
stretch of the imagination that's true
but those observational skills are
interesting aren't they when when people
come in to do experimental physical like
oh I've got all these coding skills and
I'm like okay so
um are you cool with getting your crane
license because you're going to need
that in the lab
and that that filled next into my
question like the books uh sorry you
mentioned that you know for Theory it's
it's summed up you know there's a
progression you take Jack you read
Jackson you read Griffith whatever it is
and then uh you move up the ladder with
Barbara Ryden past guest on the podcast
the most influential uh cosmology book
uh in the world right now for
undergraduates
um and it's all these series of just
like home run after home run and and to
the cricket Century am I getting a
cricket Century or is Cricket popular
down where you are it is it is the
tennis is on at the moment so I don't
know I'm not sure okay Ace I'll say hey
guys yeah so you know it's just uh it's
just one after another and then to the
extent you're right that we teach
experiments it's canned experiments
Black Box experiments uh some from 200
years ago and and then of course you
start with the uh balls rolling down
inclined planes and then we wonder like
why aren't students interested in this
but um I wonder my impression of being
in experimental physicist for the last
30 plus years is that getting like the
answer whatever that number is is like
not even half the battle and most of
what we do correct me if I'm wrong in
your field uh is is looking at the ways
that you could be wrong in other words
the thing we don't teach the students
like we did we do the Davis and germer
experiment we do
um you know Cloud chamber stuff all the
stuff cool fun amazing you know things
that you describe in your book right we
do all those and if you don't get the
right answer if you do like the
Cavendish experiment you get the wrong
answer as I did many times in my
undergraduate career it's because of you
it's not because of the universe right
so so we're taught to get the answer you
know 6 times 10 to the minus or whatever
for Newton's capital G or whatever it is
or the Milliken oil drop experiment that
you also talk about now my problem is
that you know that where the answer is
so half the fun of being a physicist is
when you don't know what the answer is
you don't even know what you're looking
for and then you have to prove to
yourself that you are not you know it's
not like it being in a court of law you
have to prove that you're right not that
you could be possibly wrong so I wonder
if we don't really do the greatest job
teaching students that the the
Challenger in the systematic errors and
the analysis of what's wrong with the
system and I wonder you know to what
extent does that drive what you do and
maybe you could explain what is the what
is the proper way to think about what we
actually do as experimentalists is it
getting the right answer is it assessing
the error bars the tolerances the bounds
you do this so well in as a particle
physicist but what is it to you what is
the the as I say the cinequanon The Core
Essence of being an experimentalist
yeah I I think um in some of that
explanation there in the question you
actually summed it up pretty well in in
my experience and opinion which is that
um you're trying to to build something
which is uh accessing an idea or
accessing something in nature
um that you don't know the answer to and
that was actually the point in my
undergraduate career when I decided and
got more serious about about physics is
first I got sort of inspired of like
what I could learn but then later I
realized I was much more interested in
the questions that didn't have answers
than the questions that that did have
answers and it took me a while to come
to that because everything I was being
taught seemed like we already knew the
answers and it was my job to catch up
and find out and learn and if I didn't
do that well enough then I wasn't smart
enough because I wasn't Einstein Etc
um you know all the things that we that
we experience as a student when we yeah
and and yet
um no one tells you that actually being
able to ask good questions is a case
skill of being a scientist and then had
having the persistence to try and see
through your own biases and mistakes and
and frustrations especially in the lab
um to convince yourself that you have
found the answer to your question
because even how you form the question
and and the many small questions that
that generates is important and yeah so
a lot of people come into say a PhD in
in my one of my labs um I still have a
lab over in the UK as well and they
think they're going to be like walking
in there taking some data doing some
fancy new thing uh and then nature yeah
and then actually they're like oh why
does the signal look this way and how do
I get rid of the noise on this signal
and uh this experiment appears to have
Gremlins inside it it appears to have a
life of its own why is it not working
the way the way that I think it is
around it suddenly it stops working and
there's two there was two wonderful
things I found in my research for the
book from from famous experimentalists
both Ernest Rutherford and JJ Thompson
and the one about Ernest Rutherford I
love which is that um he firmly believed
that the more you swear at an experiment
the more likely it is to work
which maybe only works in the in the
sort of Aussie context but um I don't
typically throw at my experiments but if
you find me doing it it's it's I'm using
Rutherford's technique it's it's
validating I mean it works for him
clearly but the other the other thing I
found and I didn't write um so much
about this in the book but I read a lot
of the autobiographies and Memoirs of
the experimentalist who whose
experiments I was writing about and JJ
Thompson's one was particularly
interesting because even to his peers he
was just like super brainy slightly
scarily smart guy right
um
and yet in his Reflections on working in
the lab he was very open with this this
sense of frustration and this sense of
having to learn your equipment and
having to learn your apparatus so well
so much better than you think you're
going to need to to know about it in
order to make any progress in in the lab
to the extent that he he wrote something
I can't remember the exact quote but it
was something along the lines of um that
when you have these things that we
already know like you were just talking
about that these theoretical ideas and
you're trying to
um reproduce it he was like the least
likely place you're going to do that is
in the physics lab like because it's
just so hard to get those those results
out in the first place and this was
really my aim in writing this writing
the story in the way that I did is to
try and put people in that mindset of
what did we actually know at this point
in time and that was very difficult in
the research process because everyone
writes the physics history backwards
from what we know now and I tried to
write it forwards I was like what did
they actually know at this point in time
what were the questions they were
actually asking and then how did it
happen that they got from there to the
knowledge that they they came to and I
think that digs into the essence of
really what we do as experimentalists
which is we are moving knowledge forward
but it does not happen in the linear way
that we're taught the sort of pigeon
version of history of physics when when
we learn the subject so I hope that
that's something people can really take
away from the story is all that work
that I put in trying to find the
forwards path through the history yeah
it really it really shines through in
the book and another thing for me you
know it's like and I'm sure you've had
this experience too where you're reading
a book by a colleague it's a popular
science or trade book as they call them
here and you're like well I kind of know
all this so I can just skip it and I
should say I read the book but I also
listened to it on audiobook and Susie
nerds the audio uh and it's just uh it's
mellifluous and lovely and it's it is a
work uh to be savored I really did
appreciate it so much and and I want to
say you know you probably left a lot on
The Cutting Room floor as you just
mentioned but one of the things that I
didn't skip over and I was like a
nagging thing that that always bothered
me that you helped to resolve in my mind
which is related to what we do as
cosmologists using the cosmic microwave
background radiation one of your
colleagues Christian reichardt uh in
Melbourne he and I and our teams are
working to investigate and measure the
properties and the mass in fact of the
only elementary particle whose mass is
currently unknown and that's the
neutrino and I always thought to myself
ah well you know let's say we
cosmologists we're so smart you know
we've measured the the geometry of the
universe the age of the universe
expansion rate you know we're so
brilliant but what a particle physicist
really believe an experimentalist in
cosmology if you know he or she is told
that we have measured the mass of a
particle because that's their domain
right and we're now we're you know stay
in your lane Keating but I didn't really
appreciate how much the humble cosmic
ray played a role and and not just for
uh the phenomenon itself but I wonder if
you could wax poetically about the
technology that it enabled and the
literal Heights that experimentalists
went to as you described in this
wonderful book
yeah I I love the the story of cosmic
rays because it just breaks open our
concept of what exists in the universe
like before the discovery of cosmic rays
I guess people looked out at the night
sky and it sort of thought oh it's all
quiet and then there's some shiny things
off in the distance you know
um and and the way it was found most
people don't don't know how what was
what motivated people to go and look for
this radiation that comes down from
space and it was that they were in the
lab sorry one second
so scientists in the lab in really the
early 1900s were they just discovered
radioactivity and so the way you
measured radioactivity at that point was
using an electroscope or an electrometer
which is literally just a really simple
device that counts electric charge or
that can tell you how much electric
charge there is and when you move an
electric scope away from a radioactive
substance the amount of charge you
should pick up should decrease
um this like one over r squared law
right and they found that actually even
when it was far away they seemed to
detect more radiation than they expected
and this was something that had plagued
them for many years and it was very
difficult because
um that was the only thing they had to
measure it with
so people started getting curious about
this why is there this extra radiation
well radiation itself had been found in
minerals from the earth so they thought
ah there just must be more radiation in
the earth in my particular area so
people started taking these things down
underwater in like submarines uh they
took them up the Eiffel Tower uh and and
they took them um even in tunnels so
that they could be surrounded by the
Earth and consistently they found that
no actually doesn't look like this extra
radiation is coming from the earth it
wasn't consistent and so then a few
people got this idea oh we're going to
take them up in hot air balloons we're
going to go up further away from the
earth and then the amount of radiation
we discover should decrease
and uh but the instruments weren't good
enough and then a new version was
invented and finally Victor Hess in
about 1911 gets this hot air balloon
does five or six different flights up to
about 5 000 feet which is what's been
freezing I don't know how we operated
the instruments at that height
um but he managed to do the first sort
of definitive set of measurements that
showed that first the radiation
decreases as you go away from the earth
from the minerals and then the amount of
radiation that he detected increased and
increased further and further as it went
up and this he concluded was radiation
coming from space interacting in the
atmosphere and then creating all
whatever it was that he was detecting
and he didn't he had no idea what it was
composed of at that point
and then almost coincidentally at the
same time one of the researchers who'd
gone in a tunnel in Scotland to try and
solve this radiation problem but wasn't
that interested in it Charles Wilson he
invents the first type of particle
detector called a cloud chamber which he
originally invented to study meteorology
and then discovered that little bits of
radiation would cause particle tracks
that went through this beautiful sort of
alcohol vapor in in or water vapor he
used originally in his chamber and so
people start taking these Cloud Chambers
up mountains like it was this incredibly
adventurous period through to like the
early 19 early mid 1930s where you get
these these Chambers with their
photographic devices wrapped in these
huge coils that form a magnet that sort
of consumes all the electricity from a
huge generator and you know that the
truck breaks down on the way up the
mountain and it's freezing and it spend
like six weeks collecting data and then
in 1932
um they found in the images from a cloud
chamber particles that looked like
electrons but were bending the wrong way
in a magnetic field which almost
immediately they realized were positrons
which the first discovered form of
antimatter but Carl Anderson who did
that experiment didn't even know that
antimatter had been predicted three
years earlier by Dirac he found it in
the experiment without knowing it was
predicted and Dirac didn't motivate
anybody to go out and do the experiment
because he didn't think it was really
real in nature he thought it was almost
like a quirk of the equations so we get
antimatter and then four years later we
also get the discovery of the muon that
no one predicted at all which is the
heavier version of the electron and from
there really we start to get this sense
of oh there is much more richness and
complexity to matter I put in inverted
commas because most people think of
matter as the stuff in front of us but
muons and positrons are not in atoms
um and and suddenly it opens up this
exploration of the subatomic world and
um even I mean it blows my mind that
we've even found uses for those
particles so
muons because they travel through Rock
they can travel through large amounts of
rock you can use them to image the
inside of a pyramid and find they found
a new empty chamber in khufu's Great
Pyramid in Giza that way
um you can even use them to image magma
inside a volcano just by putting
detectors either side and using the
cosmic ray muons and then positrons are
amazing because you can use
radioisotopes that emit positrons inside
the human body to trace out the
functions of the human body using
positron emission tomography scanners so
again like linking up okay people went
out and found these things almost
serendipitously even the instruments
were invented almost serendipitously and
then today you know if I need my thyroid
scanned I go in the hospital and I just
don't think twice about it about you
know oh there's a scanner there well
look at the back story of that scanner
it's absolutely incredible yeah it truly
is and actually I wanted to uh I want to
talk more about serendipity in the time
we have left but first of all to talk
more about your your actual work and
what you're doing now in medical and
device physics and and just to remind
listeners we're talking Professor Susie
Sheehy author of the matter of
everything uh and I shouldn't show you
one of my kids as a t-shirt that he got
from one of his friends
and it said um uh you matter on the
front of it and it says unless you
multiply by c squared then you energy
and I got so mad at that shirt because
it's like no it's not matter it's Mass
come on uh but anyway you can't correct
uh what these t-shirt manufacturers are
doing nowadays but uh but we're talking
Susie author of uh the matter of
everything and now the kind of pivot
that takes place in this book at least
for you professionally is that you know
spoiler alert you you know you kind of
win the day the heroine's journey she's
now Professor the coveted you know goal
of of Science and maybe if we get a
chance to talk some other time maybe
here or there uh we'll get into more of
the what I call the academic Hunger
Games and how hard it is and how uh just
just impressive you are and how much
stuff you've done to get where you are
but talk about what you do what what is
the science that you're involved with
the application ranging from what Alfred
Nobel really wanted with his Nobel
prizes as I talk about in my book my
first book and you talk about in your
book
um which was serendipitously discovered
but it was to benefit mankind they said
mankind back then now you'd say
humankind but this was a medical device
but it was invented by a physicist talk
about that tradition that you're
carrying on so proudly today right so so
much of the discovery and innovation in
this story
um actually traces the path through the
invention of particle accelerators which
are you know the tools the main tools
that we have now uh to explore the first
inside the atom and then to explore well
beyond that and these particles that are
out there in the universe but along the
way as each of these new technologies
was invented and new ideas came along of
how to pull particles out of the atom
you know form them into a bunch and give
them a lot of energy in a very precise
way and that itself became a whole field
of physics which is called accelerator
physics which is the field that I work
in so rather than you know I don't
although I studied it I don't daily use
you know Quantum field Theory and all of
these things I'm I'm I'm back there
using you know mostly Advanced
electromagnetism non-linear Dynamics
things like that and what my role is is
I'm trying to go back to the drawing
board of how it is that we can take
these particles and give them energy on
on some fundamental way and uh and
trying to understand how we can
reconfigure particle accelerators to
make better use of those particles and
produce better quality beams for all
sorts of applications so my previous
work was actually in China produce very
high intensity beams now that's
important for particle physics because
you just get more collisions if you have
higher intensity beams
um but it's important in some other
areas as well
um like Neutron generation for Neutron
spillation Source facilities like big
scientific facilities that other people
use and the challenge there is quite
interesting right most people don't
think about this you can only accelerate
a Charged particle with an electric
charge and yet large things repel each
other and most people don't think about
this because they think about if you
picture a beam in a particle accelerator
most people in their Mind's Eye kind of
picture a laser beam right like this
organized collection that goes forward
but light's easy because it doesn't push
itself apart in the way that a Charged
particle beam will so if you try and
pack a whole lot of charged particles in
there imagine tiny galaxies as the
Bunches of particles rotating swirling
doing all these crazy non-linear effects
interacting with each other interacting
with the magnets and the beam pipe
there's electrical and magnetic fields
flying around everywhere there's all
sorts of stuff going on and yet we need
to be able to control that while it's
going around almost at the speed of
light uh so that we lose less than one
particle in a million or we risk melting
the machine down right so this is
incredibly important that we got this
right so sometimes will be a person in
there you know too right for added added
difficulties
not too far away that's the thing and
then and then when we get to
Applications then yeah you're taking
that same physics and you want to get
that right because at the end of that
device you're placing a patient who has
a tumor and you're trying to treat that
tumor very very precisely
um in in multiple forms both either with
heavy particles or with X-rays and
radiation so then it becomes even more
important that we understand exactly
what's happening with that beam and how
to how to control it yet at the same
time there's always this pressure
everything has to be smaller everything
has to be cheaper everything everything
has to be more effective and the way
that we can do that is going back to the
going back to the physics drawing board
and going right how can we change this
system such that we can shrink these
things down and make them cheaper and
better and more purpose built for the
applications that we have most people
don't realize that there's not just two
or three particle accelerators in the
world doing physics stuff there's like
50 3000 particle accelerators in the
world and about half of them are medical
and about half of them are industrial
and like a tiny tiny fraction is used
for people here in San Diego or in
California generally they're like we
don't want to build any more you know
nuclear reactors for power they're
dangerous or like do you realize just in
San Diego Bay there's like six nuclear
reactors and submarines and aircraft
like you don't just like oh they turn
off when they get to Port no they're but
of course yours your technology is is
used for a very peaceful purposes and I
wonder as happened with people ranging
from you know the first snowball
Laureate uh yeah with uh the discovery
of what we now call Rent getting raise
no we I still wish we called them
renkinry I think it's fun they still do
in in places in some x-ray departments
in Germany it's still called volcanology
or yeah Rankin race yep but I think yeah
you said that he he's the one who gave
it that distinction and then later there
were things called n rays and then now
we have beta rays and so forth um that
was serendipitous and I wonder you know
dovetailing back to the question that we
were just kind of ruminating on with
with
um at the start which was you know these
larger and larger accelerators so to
speak I wonder if we're going to come
full circle in that my fears will be
allayed that we couldn't really maybe
have counted on particle physicists to
trust you know cosmologists unless there
were the discovery of cosmic rays Etc
and we wouldn't have predicted that you
could get this device for removing
tumors you know from a particle from a
cloud chamber or you know from an
electroscope but you you proved the
pathway direct lineage and Heritage
there but I wonder are we going to come
full circle where we can no longer build
bigger and bigger instruments of the
kype you talk about the cost and even
though as you rightfully point out it's
a tiny fraction of the cost that I think
Americans spend on lipstick every year
is the NSF or NASA's budget nevertheless
uh it's not likely I mean pass guest
James Beacham has talked about putting a
collider on the the moon you know we'll
see when you know my great great
grandkids are graduate students maybe
that'll happen what do you see as the
future
um do you think we're going to stifle
Innovation because we will simply have
picked all the low-hanging fruit by the
successes of the men and women that you
talk about in this book have we outdone
ourselves in that there's really
unlikely to be discoveries tantamount to
you know the CT MRI pet technology all
the stuff that you work on and
contribute to or stuff that I contribute
to in cosmological experiments which are
also getting big have we picked all the
low-hanging fruit or is there hope are
you more optimistic than than
pessimistic yeah my initial response to
that is I'm probably more optimistic
than than pessimistic around it first of
all with like the big the large-scale
experiments I think I you know I've come
to realize that one of the lovely things
about the serendipitous way or and the
society unexpected way in which science
progresses is that sometimes a kind of
left field suggestion will actually end
up taking over and this happens in my
field at least this has happened again
and again to revolutionize the
technology with some new idea that's
come in and so let me just give you a
hint of one of those is that one of the
limitations in
and why the accelerators are so big is
because you can only accelerate so much
using a voltage right because at some
point you're going to have electrical
breakdown well if you take a system
that's already electrically broken down
like a plasma and you start generating
electric and magnetic fields in that
you're not limited by breakdown anymore
and that's exactly what people are
looking at in plasma based accelerators
so driving that either with a laser or
another particle beam to try and create
electric wake fields that can accelerate
particles and even in my career you know
even in the last 10 15 years that has
come from almost completely theoretical
concept to something where they're now
working with industry to make
small-scale tests of whether or not they
can use this for x-ray Imaging depending
on the scale of things so like that that
development is incredible and I'm
keeping a very close watching eye on on
that field at the moment because if that
technology gets the point where I think
we can really use it for large-scale
accelerators oh I'll be in there trying
to work with them on how tell you how
you put this stuff together how you put
our existing knowledge together with
their crazy plasma stuff and um and
generate the next generation of machines
and maybe it's something like that that
allows us to go beyond the energy Reach
For example that one you know a machine
the size of the Moon would require and
instead build a smaller system by being
smarter and by taking the ideas that we
know and combining them together and
that's where I have this the thing that
I often say that the sort of utility of
these ideas really grows over time so
I'm optimistic that we will solve those
sorts of challenges and won't have to
put all our eggs in one basket and go
very very slowly for decades
that I had a visitor come in not a
graduate student but a young a young
child so hopefully he's out of out of
earshot range now but I can tell
something was going on I was like what's
going on if I have a time
uh yeah well uh we'll make sure we
doctor that up um so we've reached the
the hour when uh I like to ask my guests
who come on a series of questions that I
call
existential questions
um we have time for two I'm going to ask
you first though a pertinent to the name
of this podcast which is called into the
impossible based on Sir Arthur C
Clarke's famous saying that the only way
to discover the limits of the possible
is to go beyond them into the impossible
and in this book you talk about
persistence and I wonder if you could
elaborate perhaps as a way to end you
know answer this question of what gave
you the courage to go into the
impossible you mentioned not only
persistence but the freedom to persist
what does that mean can you elaborate on
what do you mean by the freedom to
persist not just the persistent the
trait of being persistent
yeah so I I say I see the trait of being
persistent or resilient as an more an
individualist approach right whereby you
know I'm struggling through something
and you're like just keep going just
keep going and I you know come into work
every day and continue working on it
um I think that's very different from
what I'm trying to get at which is the
freedom to persist is more a cultural
phenomenon where it's like are we
creating environments in which people
can actually persist without having to
give up all the time and this you know
in some other occasion could lead to us
really analyzing the structure of how we
do research and how Academia Works in
particular we always have all of these
different pressures on us now more so
than in you know 100 years ago
um the stories that I've told in the
book uh you know because most of the men
had wives at home they were free to just
sort of do their thing their experiments
didn't cost much so the funding was
available and they could just basically
sit and think and work and and do all of
that now oh my goodness you know the
role of an academic we have like 17
different jobs in in one when we do
research and then we're constantly
constantly having to find funding to
keep our research going and that is such
a killer for creativity and curiosity it
means that we're much less likely to
take risks with our research and we're
much less likely to follow our curiosity
because we're like oh that little thing
that's happening over there in my
experiment that I don't understand oh
I'll just assume it's not important
whereas it might have actually been the
discovery of something completely new if
you you know depending on obviously the
scale of experiment that you do so to me
the freedom to persist is quite an
important one because it's about giving
the people the opportunity to actually
pursue the goals that they're looking at
and that's a real shift in perspective
societally as well in how we value
research and how we value this activity
which seems on the surface to not
day-to-day produce something which has
monetary capitalistic value right and
even though in the long term as I've
shown in the book it might have it also
might not have and we still need to
Value it even if it doesn't produce
capitalistic outcome maybe this hundred
year period is the period that had the
great capitalistic outcome and from here
on out particle physics is not going to
produce anything that someone can
monetize we should not stop it
even if that's the case because we are
humans who want to know things and and
making sure that we give people the
capacity the time the resources the
space to actually pursue those questions
kind of on behalf of humanity that
sounds very grand
um no is that true giving people that
that capacity is such an important thing
and if we hadn't done that previously
yeah I mean if you ever feel you know
kind of uh shy about you know exploring
the virtues of of experimental research
and basic research because maybe it's
not monetizable I mean think about Dirac
you know or Hamilton you know somebody
says what use are these Spinners you
know what what use are these you know
quaternions you know well someday
they'll describe antimatter which will
then be used to make positroni Mission
tomorrow you know it's like you could
never ever predict it right right and
famously famously it's like what what
use was electricity right you know even
back in the day and and uh you know the
experimenter says I'm I'm not sure but
one day you'll tax it well exactly
and I think that's the thing we're so
limited and we're so limited in how we
can imagine the future use of these
ideas that are coming out and that is
really the nub of the story I've tried
to tell is stop limiting ourselves to go
oh well what use is that going to be
when you want the result in three years
in a small Grant from the government
right no no the use might take decades
it might take centuries but the
knowledge is what's important right and
and what what uses is is a discovery
that never comes about because you're so
gung-ho about about monetizing it and
it's very short-sighted
um so uh Professor Sheehy last question
that I like to ask guests also comes
from Sir Arthur C Clarke where he said
um when an elderly but distinguished
scientist says something is possible she
is almost certainly right but when she
says something is impossible she is very
likely wrong I want to ask you what do
you change your mind about what have you
been wrong about or what have you been
maybe misdirected about and later found
to be completely surprised or
serendipitously so
um what have you been wrong about if
anything
[Music]
oh that's a that's a really that's a
really good question
um
I think actually uh
I what I was wrong about was whether or
not I could be a physicist this is quite
a personal answer to that question I
think yeah please please I'm sorry I
didn't mean to imply that you're elderly
I just meant to imply you're
distinguished go ahead
I can take it
um yeah so so you know as you said
before like obviously to get to the the
point that as a fully fledged academic
running a group
um and and sort of having that permanent
academic position uh was always
something that I thought well you know
I'm in this for the research and if that
career doesn't work out that's that's
fine by me it may never work out
statistically it's unlikely to to work
out but I also underestimated my own
ability I think to to do research partly
because of the factors we were talking
about earlier about it's so dependent on
things like persistence and asking good
questions rather than just about whether
or not you can solve a mathematical
problem faster than your peers right so
we're given this wrong impression in the
early years of our training and the
other aspect of it for me was very much
that I felt somehow different often to
the people around me the primary one was
was gender but often it was just because
I you know I uh have these many
different interests in the world
including things like uh wanting to
contribute to something which helps
society as well as wanting to contribute
to the fundamental questions in in the
world and so uh I guess for a long time
I I was under the impression that like
okay well I'll just do some research for
other people and then eventually I'll
probably go on and work for a company or
maybe I'll do science communication and
write books uh or end up doing both I
suppose
um and and so that that's the thing that
I was wrong about and that was one of
the lovely things in writing this book
and finding the stories of all the other
women who went before me was just
realizing that and even a lot of the men
they all had that very similar
experience
um most of them felt like for most of
their career that they were failing
right and being able to sit with that
move through that persist do research
anyway and and come out and go oh
actually if they can do it you know and
they all wonder what prizes all the
people I'm writing about I'm like well
I'm not going to win a Nobel Prize but
you know maybe I can do this after all
and so um yeah it's such a delight and
it's a gift to Young uh young minds and
I think that's the the surest test if
you've succeeded is would you have how
much would you have paid for this book
when you were you know a young student
and I think I think that's the truest
test and I expect you know for you as it
is for me this is a wonderful book and
it's a it's a much needed book as I say
I love my uh theorist friends I've had
on more than almost anybody from all
walks of theory and even I've had on
economists and but um but there's
something to be said for those of us
that are confronting the cold hard
reality uh not just as as you say of of
understanding the logic and the
mechanisms that we're searching for but
also the the budgets the the persuasion
the confidence that it takes to get to a
point as you have surely gotten to and
will continue to do so and I can't wait
to see what you come up with next Susie
it's been a delight to talk to you
congratulations this is thanks for
smashing success and um it is a book to
be savored so please do pick up copies
either digital audio or print it as uh I
have consumed it all those formats I can
attest to them Susie thank you so much
thank you lovely to know that with you
for a bit yeah it's and we'll nerd out
again hopefully uh in person someday
foreign
[Music]